do
[Music]
welcome to session 57 of the worlds of
speculative fiction series today we are
going to be discussing this massive toll
a single novel by neil stevenson
anathem which came out in 2008
and uh has been you know
read by by millions of people worldwide
as it points out on the jacket number
one new york times bestseller at least
back in the day and it is a book that
people have rather
strong opinions about for reasons that
we'll talk about in a bit i want to say
two things before we
actually get started so the first is if
you're new to this series
this is a set of talks that were
originally face to face hosted at the
brookfield public library beginning in
2016 there is an entire playlist of all
the previous ones uh we've got others
lined up in advance and there's sort of
a regular sequence to this once a month
there is a talk and we focus on world
building we talk usually a little bit
about the biography of the authors and
we look at philosophical themes in the
works and you know this novel and in
particular has a lot of philosophical
themes because they were deliberately
placed there but there's others that we
can raise as well and discuss
when covid hit we went on hiatus for a
bit because we couldn't meet at the
library and then we
meandered our way into this new format
where
i do a presentation by video for about
an hour and a half sometimes going a bit
longer and then we spend some time uh
engaging in a video conferencing with
the people who are the really dedicated
fans who want to talk about this or
other uh speculative fiction matters or
even just philosophy so that's thing
number one
thing number two
it's been a while since i have done one
of these because i've been hung up on
this book for
quite a while we're going to talk about
the nature of this book in just a little
bit but i want to say this
it is for many people a slow and rough
start i would say i had to get you know
at least 200
maybe 250 pages in
before i was getting
even really that interested
in the work and that may have more to do
with me than with the work itself or
with you as a
reader but i you know it is something
that is we're going to see reviewers
talking about this it might take a while
for you to
get into it and you know i found myself
each month having to put off the session
that what we're doing right here
to another month
until i could actually finish the the
whole book now granted some of that is
due to my own busyness
and but some of it also had to do with
you know
slowly trudging through the
the molasses
of the first
yeah first third of the book and then
you know getting into the swing and
being able to proceed with the the rest
of this massive
volume so i think that's kind of an
important feature
the last thing i'll say right here is
that
if you
are haven't read the book there are
going to be some spoilers ahead i don't
think that they're going to be spoiler
spoilers in the sense of oh the story is
you know just completely damaged and we
can't read it or think about it anymore
but there are going to be some spoilers
we can't discuss this book without going
into some of those
i don't know that that many people are
going to
read their way through this entire thing
but if this if this you know
presentation helps get you interested in
the book that's great if you've already
read it and you you know find something
that you want to talk about you can
write something in the comments or in
the live chat when this is running and
you know i'll be happy to address that
so
all that said let's jump
into
looking at the
world itself some some biography some
philosophical themes we are also going
to be looking at uh stevenson's own
interviews which might be a good place
to start with this and some of the
reviews that i think bring up important
points about this work
before we launch into the discussions of
world building and stevenson's own takes
on anathem and and what he's trying to
do in it and some of the philosophical
themes and what other people have had to
say about it
we should do a brief biographical
exposition here we have a
living author and one who is hopefully
not near the end of his career so
there's there's a lot to say but also
there's not quite as long of a timeline
stevenson is in his early
60s at this point in time
so you know it's not this this massive
backstory like some of the authors that
we've gone into
before
so
he's born in
1959
in fort meade maryland and he comes from
you could you could say a technical
and intellectual family his father was a
professor of electrical engineering his
mother worked in a biochemistry
laboratory so we've got two
science-oriented people growing up in
the household that he's growing up in
her father was a biochemistry professor
so not only in terms of
technical capacity and the sciences but
also
a connection with uh universities and
research
and stevenson um you know grows up in
this environment his family moves to
champaign urbana which if you don't know
the geography of the midwest that is
where the flagship
state university of illinois happens to
be you know there's lots of other
illinois colleges and universities but
that one is sort of the the big one sort
of like uw madison or sort of like uh
nor you know university of north
carolina chapel hill it's it's it's
you know the
the one that gets the best funding the
one that has the most people gathered
there it's the one that in certain
respect is the most university
town and then eventually they move to
ames iowa
stevenson is going to graduate from ames
high school and then he's going to go to
boston university so kind of a trek
and he first specializes
in physics he actually works as a
teaching assistant in the physics
department
and then he switches to geography and
you might say well that's kind of a
weird thing to do isn't it and there's a
few things to say about geography so the
official thing that you find out in the
research is that he switched to
geography because he found out this
would give him more
time
on the computer
mainframe
than being a physics major which he
continued to minor in
and you could say well how the hell
would that be the case well you know
geography was it and still is a very
multi-disciplinary discipline as a
matter of fact in the time that he's in
it was it was kind of a growing
discipline
and there were lots of problems that
required the use of statistical modeling
or you know computer
algorithms but there weren't that many
people who were old school who were
getting into that so it would make sense
that as opposed to a discipline like
physics or mathematics or god forbid
computer science
uh geography people would be
sharing like maybe the same amount of
total time among fewer
students but geography was also like i
said a multi-disciplinary discipline at
that time and so that would have exposed
him to interconnections between
uh the various disciplines which i think
is is quite important for the
development of um somebody who's going
to be doing the kind of work that
stevenson would do he he worked as a
research assistant
for the u.s department of energy
in ames
iowa he also worked as a researcher for
the corporation for a cleaner
commonwealth in boston
and then he finally graduates in 1981
with a ba in geography and a minor in
physics and then you know he works as a
clerk in a library and he's starting to
do some writing
his first two novels um
didn't get much play at all the big u
which is you know sort of a looking at a
university town you write what you know
right and
he publishes that in 1984 so just a few
years after he gets out of college then
he marries uh ellen marie lackerman the
year after that they will have two
children together
he publishes another more
thriller-oriented novel called zodiac
and then finally makes it big in 1992
with snow crash and this is a
cyberpunk sometimes described as post
cyber punk novel which brings together a
whole bunch of the themes that were
floating around at the time
so you know there's there's some social
uh
commentary in it about
capitalism collectivism corporation
stuff like that there's a lot of
computer stuff a lot of speculation
about what the the internet is going to
look like you know obviously who's the
big uh
person on the scene william gibson this
is sort of like taking gibson's stuff
perhaps a little bit further
and then he works with his uncle to to
publish some other things as well
in 1995 he publishes the diamond age or
young ladies illustrated primer and
a little bit after that this is 1999
he tells us that he was present at the
origins of blue origin originally blue
operations llc
and was its only
employee for a little while and so he
did all sorts of things from you know
laying ethernet cable to you know
putting systems together and this is his
his look into an entrepreneurial
landscape you could say
that same year he brings out
kryptonomicon
and uh you know this will eventually win
the prometheus hall of fame award
following that in 2003 2004 and 2004
again he will bring out this baroque
cycle originally three books broken up
into more books later on uh system of
the world wins the prometheus award so
now he's really starting to get some
some notice 2006 he leaves blue origin
because he's finding it's just becoming
like another aerospace company
in 2008
he write or publishes anathem
and this will win the locus award for
best science fiction novel in 2009
so that's the story up until the
publishing of anathem what has he been
doing after that
in 2010
um he's named chairman of the subatai
corporation
and they begin the production of a
multimedia fiction project called the
mongoliad and stevenson is writing part
of that along with some other
speculative fiction writers he also
publishes a novel called read me
in 2011
which centers around
some some you know massive online
game developers caught in in some real
life things with some some really bad
guys
um in 2012 he branches out in another
direction
launching a kickstarter campaign for a
realistic sword fighting fantasy game
which would use
motion control to provide an immersive
experience it was called clang
they managed to hit the funding goal
and um they they accepted uh you know
further donations and then by 2013
as is the case with so many things or
there's funding they run out of it they
use it all up right
yeah they never really deliver on the
product
a lot of the backers get quite angry it
ends in 2014
without being completed leading some
people to threaten a class action
lawsuit
2014 he's also hired as chief futurist
which is kind of a cool uh title a cool
gig to have by
the augmented reality company magic leap
and i should say this in his interviews
stevenson
is less bullish on virtual reality a
completely immersed you know thing where
we jack in and we're in some virtual
world and we're all on our own
and he's much more bullish about
augmented reality where we're you know
we're moving around in the world that we
inhabit but it's been augmented in some
way you might remember back uh in the
day with you know the the glasses google
glass was bringing out these glasses
that would have things going on on there
and we called the people wearing them
glass holes because they were
narcissistically oblivious to everybody
else around them uh you know and so
augmented reality is is kind of like
that it's not you're not going
completely into a fantasy world you
might think about uh you know a great
example of that was the pokemon craze
right before kovid people were out and
about you know catching pokemons all
over the place through their phones
that would be an example of augmented
reality so he joins
magic leap to to
work on that sort of stuff publishes a
couple more works um
uh seven eves in 2015 the rise and fall
of dodo in 2017
and
in 2019 he publishes this novel fall or
dodge in hell
and it contains some characters from
some of his early works 2020 he gets
laid off from magic leap which is you
know uh
cutting people and stuff like that and
then he makes some lemons out of that
that or he makes some lemonade
out of those lemons that'd be the
reverse wouldn't it uh he and his
colleagues uh stuart and grossman
release newfoundland the long haul an
audible audio drama
based on intellectual property they
developed at magic leap
finally his latest book published in
2021
very recently termination shock a
climate fiction novel about solar geo
engineering featuring some interventions
to try to deal
with the climate crisis and you know he
did some interviews about this recently
i'll just mention this because we're
going to talk about other interviews in
just a bit
and he says um you know the climate
crisis
there there are these events like the
heat wave in seattle that killed people
and this is going to keep happening in
other places but that doesn't get
everybody's
imagination psyches captured the way
that rising sea levels do when you are
under water or water is seeping in
suddenly you realize that there is a
problem so that's probably enough about
biography at this point
it's always good to hear from an author
him or herself about the work that
they're doing and you know we're really
fortunate with neil stephenson to have a
living author who has given a number of
interviews about his work in general and
specifically
about this novel there's a lot of
material out there
i'm just going to read you a few of the
things from some of the interviews that
i think are particularly
helpful or revealing
so on the book page
um for anathem he tells us in 1999 danny
hills asked me and several other people
to contribute back of napkin sketches
depicting our conceptions of the clock
of the long now these were never
intended as serious design proposals it
was more of an exercise to show how
different people thought about the idea
at the time many newspapers and
magazines had been publishing end of
decade end of century and even end of
millennium news summaries in addition to
the end of year ones that come out every
december
i got to thinking about the amount of
time and energy i spend each day
keeping up on current events i know i'm
going to forget in 24 hours
what if i only read the newspaper once a
year
once a decade
once a century
i'd know a lot less about current events
but i'd have plenty of spare bandwidth
to think about other things
i embodied these musings into my back of
napkin sketch for danny which depicted a
system of concentric walls surrounding
the clock tower and enclosing cloistered
communities with progressively
deeper separation from current events
that simply
is the basis for the world depicted in
anathem in the maths
with you know those that open have an
app hurt once a year
once a decade once a century once a
millennium with different communities of
people inside the possibility of moving
back and forth between them
and the different what we might say
courses of development that would be
enabled by this disconnection from the
larger secular
world
there's an mit interview in which he was
asked about
one idea or concept that inspired the
new novel anathem
and
here he was a little bit more cagey he
says in general i prefer the reader to
decide but i don't want to be totally
sphinx like and so i'll permit myself to
say a little
as far as culture and politics are
concerned the important theme is long
attention span
versus short attention span thinking
i'm sure your readers can think of any
number of ways in which having a longer
attention span can be useful but i'll
name one
bankers with long attention spans don't
lend money to people who can't pay it
back
what's he referring to there
the
financial collapse that began in 2007
and extended into 2008 and well into the
2010s right why did that happen because
bankers made a lot of stupid you know uh
very short-term decisions about shaky
financial instruments that they didn't
understand very well and about the
housing market and about and about it
was all short-term thinking rather than
long attention span thinking
if he said we if we had bankers who
adopted a long-term view of their
responsibilities we might not be in the
middle of a financial crisis that is
blowing away 150 year old investment
banks
so
what would it be like to have
a society in which at least a portion
of that society is not thinking in terms
of the next quarter the next year the
next uh few years the next election
cycle but rather in terms of
decades
hundreds of years millennia of
development
ongoing development
good question
in the uh la times interview
scott timberg asks him a number of
questions
the first is anathem is set on a
different planet in a different universe
neil stephenson says as a kid reading
science fiction i was always fascinated
with parallel universe situations
situations where someone gets jumped
into another universe that's similar to
ours with a hand-wavy
pseudo-physics explanation for how it
happened i wanted to come up with my own
hand-wavy pseudo-physics explanation now
isn't that an interesting thing to say
because
you know
you there is a physics theory basis for
the four
previous civilizations including our own
who uh come to to
arb
and you know interact with the
inhabitants there but it's you know it's
pseudo-physics right it's you could call
it philosophical speculative physics if
you wanted
the next question your books are driven
by ideas but they've got to have
something else to work
as novels neil stephenson says oh
there's a lot of ideas that bang around
they're kind of like seeds which fall on
barren ground and on a good day i can
take one of those ideas and see how it
fits in with some characters and a story
and then i've got something if that's
not there it's all a complete waste of
time
he also says
that he doesn't plot out the timelines
and structures of his world uh
necessarily he says if you do it that
way you're at some hazard of
shortchanging what people really read
books for
which is characters and stories
it's better to take a leap of faith and
start telling the story it's probably a
rookie mistake if you lack confidence in
your ability to fill all that in you'll
sit a long time working on the map
then finally he's asked about canticle
for leibowitz walter miller's book
what about it that has a
post-apocalyptic monastery setting and
did that have an influence on your new
novel and then uh stevenson i think this
is great says
it's a different premise from anathem in
a lot of ways when people hear about
monks in sci-fi that's the one they
think of and rightly so but when you
look at it from a geek's point of view
there must have been zillions of science
fiction books over the year with monks
in them
canticle for lieberwitz
shouldn't be our automatic go-to
reference point and this highlights a
danger that that comes up within
a lot of um
criticism you know well this has
something in common with this so
therefore there must be a connection
between them when that isn't really
necessarily the case
there's a very interesting interview in
good reads
where
it's you know he's being asked as an
intellectual yourself
would you find the
technology-obsessed future world in
which people are focused on immediate
gratification would you find this living
situation to be a utopia or a prison and
stevenson says
it's meant to be ambiguous in that way
i'm not going to kill the ambiguity by
giving you a straight answer
but i will point out that in the world
of the book the ones in the cloisters
are free to leave at any time they can
go back onto the general population and
try to make their way in a world like
anyone else so they're making a decision
every day as to whether it's a utopia or
a prison and whether the outside would
be better or worse
then there's a discussion about the
glossary of terms and
stevenson says i'm hoping the book is
accessible to habitual science fiction
readers and non-science fiction readers
alike one of the skills that science
fiction readers develop after reading a
few thousand science fiction novels is
picking up the details of a new world
through a kind of osmosis they just
plunge and start reading unfamiliar
names and words appear undeterred they
plow ahead slowly their subconscious
mind assembles a picture of the world
by page 100 or so they know the meanings
of all those words every kid in america
knows the meanings of words like
horacrux and wisdom gamat that are used
in the harry potter novels but there's
also many readers who are more
accustomed to books in which every word
can be looked up in a dictionary and
they find it distracting or even
annoying to encounter new terms in a
work of fiction for them i included a
glossary
use it or not depending on what sort of
reader you are now i'll admit i actually
have used the glossary
so maybe maybe i'm the kind of reader
who likes the you know let's stick in
the the language that we already have
right um
i think there's really something here
this is a really great point that he's
making
when we're going into a narrative world
we do pick things up
um i don't know if we would call it
osmosis there's an associative process
that takes place um read enough other
literature in this on this world in
other areas and you will pick it up as
well great example of this is reading
stuff in stoicism where the words don't
always mean what we think that they
typically mean and there's all sorts of
technical terms read enough read around
enough in the classic text and
eventually things start to coalesce and
you're like ah i can see the world the
way that they're they're portraying it
well we can see the world as stevenson
is portraying it through the eyes of
right um and so
oh actually other characters too we do
get a lot of other points of view
being brought in even though erasmus is
the point of view uh narrator so you
know i think he's he's right about this
and
you know the uh
lexicon can be a little bit uh precious
and annoying at times but you know if
you write a thousand page book i guess
you get to do that right
there's another
interesting interview in scientific
american
in anathem the central core concept of
the book is that consciousness as we get
much later on is a quantum mechanical
property that's a new and controversial
idea did you read popular science
articles to bone up on those concepts
and
stevenson says well that's actually an
idea that's been around for a while the
hardline position is that the brain is
too wet and too warm to allow for
quantum effects there's also the
insurgent position that evolution may
have found a way to take advantage of
quantum effects even though it is a warm
and wet environment chloroplasts and
plants may make use of quantum
superposition to do what they do it's an
open question in science between the
mainstream the hardliners who say it's
impossible with what we already know and
the fringe people who say it's possible
but they use methods that are not
generally accepted there are people in
the middle who try to figure out what
may be true it's in the middle where the
good material for science fiction comes
from
these are areas of current interest that
can turn a story
well that's another interesting insight
isn't it
so as opposed to like the
what it is that science at the time is
teaching us the you know the consensus
which may not be a genuine consensus
um and the fringe which may include all
sorts of kooky people and you know weird
whacked out stuff but also some
legitimate outliers there's a middle
area where we can
work from
and i think this is uh this is kind of a
interesting concept that stevenson is
putting forth there terms of world
building and
literary development right
there's a long
interview in gizmodo
that's summarized by by the writer
and um
[Music]
so here's i'm going to read some
sections from this and then maybe
comment on a bit of it
i asked stevenson about this alliance
between the avut and deoliters the
dayliliers are people who who
believe that there is a god and you know
obviously worship the god
and he said i'd take issue with your
reading of the book here
i don't really think the scientists and
the dialers forge an alliance to me this
seems like unduly feel good reading of
the book during the last half of the
book they worked together under the
terms of the reconstitution which is a 3
700 year old document
at the very end we see a few tentative
bridges being constructed between the
avut and a minority of the dialeters who
happen to be unusually compatible with
them but that's way too strong to say
that they're forging an alliance it's
not science and religion coming together
and you know one big happy family
um
he goes on any and he says
since stevenson's already mentioned the
novel is at least a tip of the hat to
earthly politics
i wondered whether he sees any
reconciliation possible between science
and religion in our own culture does he
believe this reconciliation would be
like on arb where a few deodors can work
with the avoo but the two cultures
remain essentially hostile to each other
and stevenson replies
there are many many examples of
legitimate scientists who espouse some
kind of religious faith so i don't see
any existential hostility
essential hostility i grew up in a
community of church-going scientists and
engineers the recent science religion
fireworks are driven by a theological
movement that is as controversial within
christianity as it is in secular culture
we could call this fundamentalism if we
wanted to although generally that in
religious studies that's reserved for
the actual fundamentalists and it
includes you know um you know
conservative catholics and and
evangelicals and all sorts of other
denominations
all of which have in common
a commission uh you know commitment to
culture wars and a emphasis on a
incoherent literal reading of the bible
say incoherent because the the readings
aren't really that literal uh they're
selectively literal right
and and that is is incompatible with
not only real science but also the i
effin love science people you know and
the people who are kind of like um
hangers on and fanboys of the science
that they don't actually understand but
just read about in in science you know
articles and magazines and things like
that um the again the middle ground
includes a lot of overlap right
there's one other thing i'm going to
read from that i asked stevenson a
pretty detailed question about the
philosophy in his novel
most of the action in anathem centers on
how the people of arab deal with aliens
who have traveled to their planet from
other timelines as the characters
discuss how this has come about they
speculate that timeline travel might
move in one direction towards timelines
that are closer to a mathematical or
philosophical ideal
i.s stevenson has a very interesting
question whether he thinks arb the
the world depicted here is more ideal
than earth because its cultures have
chosen to segregate theoretical
scientists from engineers and
politicians
he answered in philosophical fashion
after warning me again this is a huge
spoiler he then explained
this is really a question about the word
ideal philosophers and non-philosophers
use it to mean different things
non-philosophers generally use it to
mean really good as in this house is
ideal for my family or i want to find
the ideal job philosophers use it to
mean something is more platonic this
doesn't necessarily mean something is
good but something closer to a pure form
so in that sense arb is more ideal than
earth not better than but simplified and
streamlined in a way that happens to be
useful for me as a novelist i think
that's a great insight about what's
going on in here so these are all things
that stevenson himself is telling us
about his own work as we find it in this
novel
there is a lot to say about the world
building involved in this novel anathem
and the plot and the world building and
character development are all connected
together
in complex ways which you know is a good
sign it's not just well let's build a
world and then like just throw the
characters into it instead because of
the point of view of uh
fra erasmus being the main character and
the one who's whose
eyes the story is being told through
we're getting bits of pieces here and
there
and there's there's a good bit of
exposition here and there in the work a
lot of revelations that are going to be
taking place
and it is indeed a real
world that a narrative world that has
been
created to give a spoiler earth is also
going to be part of that narrative world
and it exists in you know whatever we
want to call it a different dimension a
different cosmos right and it's
connected to this world of arb that
everything is is set on
where fraurasmus grows up now stevenson
does something kind of interesting
the very first so there's there's two
things that are really quite important
here he begins with
a dictionary entry for anathem right
what the the whole thing is named after
in proto-orth the poetic or musical
invocation of our mother haile which
since the time of uh adracones has been
the climax of the daily literature hence
the flukish word anathem meaning a song
of great emotional resonance especially
one that inspires listeners to sing
along note
this sense is archaic and used only in a
ritual context where it is unlikely to
be confu confused with a much more
commonly used sense number two
in new orth an out by which an
incorrigible fra or sir is ejected from
the math and his or her work sequestered
hence the flukish word anathema meaning
intolerable statements or ideas see
throwback
now there's a lot to to comment on in
that and we're going to come to that in
just a moment but first the other thing
is
a note to the reader
anathem
begins with this little note by
stevenson
if you are accustomed to reading works
of speculative fiction and enjoy
puzzling things out on your own skip
this note
otherwise know that the scene in which
this book is set is not earth but a
planet called arb that is similar to
earth in many ways and then he starts
giving us
pronunciation hints arb is pronounced
like arb with a little something on the
end consult a french person for advice
in a pinch arb will do two dots above a
vowel are a di racist meaning that the
vowel in question gets a syllable all of
its own so for example dayat is
pronounced dayat rather than diet
there's a
you know umlaut above the the a and then
he tells us about arbonne measurement
units that have been translated into
ones used on earth where the earth
speaking culture of this book has
developed vocabulary based on the
ancient precedence of arb i have coined
words based on the old languages of
earth anathem is the first and most
conspicuous example it is a play on the
words anthem and anathema which derived
from latin and greek words right and he
goes on and then he tells us names of
some arban plant and animal species have
been translated into rough earth
equivalents so these characters may
speak of carrots potatoes dogs cats etc
this doesn't mean that arb has exactly
the same species naturally arb has its
own plants and animals right and then he
gives a
timeline
he says a very brief chronology of arabs
history follows none of this will make
much sense until you've read some pages
into the work but after that it may be
useful for reference and it begins at
minus 3 40 to you know 3 30 the
approximate era of
uh canos and his daughters dayat and
hailea
so the ancient history and goes all the
way up to
the time of uh plus
36.89 when our story opens now that's
not all
we also have
towards the end um
after the the story concludes
uh with the final chapter reconstitution
a glossary which
is not a complete glossary it doesn't
include all the entries that we
might want but it is uh quite quite
interesting and quite useful there you
know for example we find out that a
dialeter is one who favors dayat's
interpretation of her father knows
vision and therefore believes in a
heaven with a god in it compare
physiologer right and then we can read
dayat one of the two daughters of knows
the other being hilaya she interpreted
her father's vision as meaning that he
had glimpsed a heavenly spiritual
kingdom populated by angelic beings
ruled by a supreme creator which is also
in one of the passages in the book that
we're going to look at
shortly so what have we got here we've
got like sort of an apparatus giving us
some of the back story you notice this
this
[Music]
what would we call a technique of saying
i'm translating these things into
language that you can relate to you
earth people this will make more sense
to you this is something that we see
again gene wolfe doing in uh the you
know the new sun books and we find a lot
of other people doing similar
things now this is one of the aspects of
the work that uh people are either hot
or cold about some people really love
this creation of new not new vocabulary
that's quite similar so let's let's
return back to this uh first entry you
know anathem
in proto-earth right uh so in early
earth uh we we have an invocation of
mother hilea we have a reference to the
adrenais we we're not sure who those are
hence the flukish word anathem you know
and we can guess well blockage must be a
language right or or a culture
and then we go on further uh and out
what's an out right well it's it's like
a ritual a ritual that involves um some
some significance by which an
incorrigible
fra or sir
okay
freyr or sir right uh brother or sister
is ejected from the math the math is not
mathematics although a lot of
mathematics goes on there the math is
where they live
and
their work is sequestered right and then
it's a see throwback throwback is
another thing uh connected with us so
there's all this
lingo that's going on
and you know for some people
uh this is really very welcome for
others like myself it can be a little
bit precious and perhaps even irritating
to have to see all this you know sound
for savant there's all sorts of
interesting little like words that have
changed a letter
um but that's part of how he's trying to
build a world and this does kind of tie
in with the
philosophy a language
is in a certain sense a structuring of
inter-subjective and intergenerational
consciousness
so
placing us into a slightly different
language
one that where we know translation has
taken place
is in a way not just a you know let's
let's liven things up by
using uh archaic language or making up
words you know neologisms it's it's a
way of trying to
put us into that narrative universe now
what can we say about this narrative
universe
it is in many respects like our own
except that the world and its culture
are
quite different in important ways
and the most important distinction
that's that's going on here
is the you could say the splitting of
the world into the secular world
where people are going out with their
lives and the secular government exists
and you know culture is happening
and that's where part of the the story
is actually going to go on and then we
have the world of
you know the the fras and the sirs the
concepts the maths the
place in which we have
something that at first
might strike you as
religious orders
but they're not really
religious orders in the sense of
committed to religious beliefs although
there's a lot of a lot of discussion
about well how exactly
how exactly should we understand these
things and the different
orders involved in this understand their
themselves their own history and what it
is that they're doing and the other
orders
in different and rivalrous ways so this
is actually
you know an important aspect of that
another key
part of this that you can say
runs throughout most of the orders is
this cartosian discipline right and what
are these well these are
rules and rituals and structures and
activities that divine
the way of living for somebody who's
committed to that and a vout that is
that is somebody who is dedicated to
this way of life and it includes a
myriad of different things that we learn
about at different points through
um
erasmus and his friends encountering
these right so
what kind of clothing you can wear um
how do you interact with your fellow
boots and with other people in the
secular world or the weird
quasi-connected thing of the ita right
it governs what you can
have as possessions and they try to live
a pretty simple life
without much technology
without computers except in certain you
know connected ways that we'll talk
about in a bit
and um
this is sort of like as many people
pointed out the rule of saint benedict
but it's not the rule of saint benedict
because it's not oriented
directly towards what the order of saint
benedict is
by the way if you don't know what the
order of saint benedict or the rule of
saint benedict
involves benedictinism or the
benedictine monasteries and nunneries
were
you could say the
most prolific and preeminent type of
monastic
orders in the west there are other
orders in other places of course in
egypt in palestine in in the
greek orthodox world in other places as
well but in the latin west the order of
saint benedict became you know probably
one of the most most important monastic
orders and also really the center of a
lot of culture you know um
many great uh uh thinkers were working
in these monasteries they also were
involved with
the state you might think of the
connection between lon frank benedict
and monk and william the conqueror lon
frank becomes archbishop of canterbury
doesn't cease being a benedictine monk
but he's doing uh both both churchly and
monastic and also
important political things along with
this new norman king and we see a
similar thing going on but with much
more conflict between anselm of
canterbury lanfrance successor and the
two uh successors to to william uh
william rufus and henry who are both
gonna have problems with with a handsome
now be that as it may
this this
understanding of
life as being structured as being put
together in a way
that
you're not inventing on the spot you're
living out
something that's been sketched for you
and lived out by many other people
before you there can be innovation there
can be development for example you know
anselm
important theologian and philosopher
also an innovator when it comes to
praying believe it or not so innovation
can take place
but it's it's oriented
not so much by
the desire to understand you know
philosophy or science or mathematics
it's ultimately oriented towards
god
now
is that the case in the orders in
anathem
there are some religious orders the
deolaters right who have an
interpretation
of you know things that that includes a
god who you know looks kind of similar
to the god of traditional theism here
but they are outliers
what is what is the
monastic
life really about here
it's about
science it's about understanding
mathematics it's about philosophy it's
about
praxix is the the term uh that we could
say you know applied science uh
engineering things that are
testable
and there's room for all sorts of
ways in which this is lived out but
there is a common discipline
in which one lives these things out
what else can we say about this at this
point that that's particularly important
well i think that one of the key aspects
of this that's particularly interesting
is um
and it's going to show up a lot in this
is that these these uh
avoots you call them monks if you want
monks and nuns but boots is is really
the term that's being used there
their
possessions are very restricted
and they basically have three
things that all of them
are are allowed to use a sphere
right an actual globe a cord
sort of like a rope and a bolt something
that they a fabric that they can wear
over themselves and these can be
you know expanded contracted knotted
together in very interesting ways they
allow for example erasmus to
use these things to escape
falling into an ice crevice he can use
the sphere to expand and and contract
and you know pull himself slowly out of
the crevice there's all sorts of uh uses
for these and they're actually made out
of a new kind of
material or matter new matter right
which is different than the matter of of
this cosmos it's artificially produced
so there's some really interesting
science going on there
that's one key aspect right the material
possessions
another really important aspect
every so often
the
the maths the monasteries
open their doors and allow the avoots to
go out into the world
for a limited time
and allow the world to come in
and they give lectures and you know the
boots go out and have adventures like
they get drunk in erasmus case he finds
his his older sister right who works in
a machine shop and there's there's all
sorts of leo goes and gets in fights
gets beaten up and beats some people up
now this is called an apert an opening
right
and it's very important because the
novel begins
at the time of an apart
and
this is how you know erasmus can go and
find his his sister cord and she's going
to be involved in the story as well
and
it allows the people on the outside to
get some idea of what's going on now
each math
is set up in a different way one one
kind of math
opens up every single year
for you know a week or so
and
those those uh boots are going to be
fairly
well connected with the outside world
right
then there's the
deccan deconary or tenors
uh math and this is where erasmus
actually lives you get to go outside
every 10 years and then you come back in
and that's how you live your life
and then there's the hundreds
which only open every hundred years and
then there's the
thousanders and the thousanders
you could say well how can anyone live
for a thousand years well they don't but
they take in newborn babies that uh you
know still have the umbilical cord
attached because they don't want their
mindset polluted by anything other than
what's going on in that monastery and we
are actually going to meet up in in the
story with one of the
thousanders right who has been you know
in that that and
throughout his entire life
so
how is this all regulated through this
clock that
is an important part of the story they
you know they're tending to it in the
early parts
um
i did have a few passages i wanted to
read because but i don't want to go too
much into this because i'm i'm a bit
worried about running out of time we
could say what is the secular outside
world like there's a lot of ways to
describe it here's one that comes in
about you know halfway through
the novel
this is erasmus
i looked with fascination at those
people in their mobes and tried to
fashion what it would be like thousands
of years ago the work that people did
had been broken down into jobs that were
the same every day in organizations
where people were interchangeable parts
all of the story had been bled out of
their lives that's how it had to be it
was how you got a productive economy
but it would be easy to see a will at
work behind this not exactly an evil
will but a selfish will the people who'd
made the system thus were jealous
not of money
and not of power
but of story
if their employees came home at day's
end with interesting stories to tell it
meant that something had gone wrong
a blackout a strike a spree killing
the powers that be would not suffer
others to be in stories of their own
unless they were fake stories that had
been made up to motivate them
people who couldn't live without stories
had been driven into the contents or
into jobs like yules
all others had to look somewhere outside
of work for a feeling that they were
part of a story which i guessed which is
why
seculars were so concerned with sports
and with religion how could you see
yourself as part of an adventure
otherwise something with the beginning
middle and end in which you played a
significant part we have had it ready
made because we were part of this
project of learning new things even if
it didn't always move fast enough for
people like jezreel it did move you
could tell where you were and where what
you were doing in that story you got all
of this for free by living his stories
from day to day and the only drawback
was the world held his stories to be of
small account
perhaps that's why he felt such a
compulsion to tell them not just about
his own exploits in the wilderness but
those of his mentors so not everybody in
the secular world is story starved in
this way but many people are they have
their jobs
things go along you know they go to the
bars they watch you know the spelies and
you know shows and and you know they
live kind of
outside of their work life dramatic
lives but they're dramatic lives that
are manufactured stories right
so there's some very interesting
reflection here what is it like to be
involved in the story of an order that
has been going on for thousands of years
carrying out some tasks going through
the process of human intellectual and
moral development every single
generation that's something that perhaps
attracts people to
religious orders or to the orders of the
avoot in this particular
story right
here's another
little vignette of the world that that
he's inventing here
the library grape
right the library grape had been
sequenced by the avoo to the content of
the lower rhone in the days before the
second sac every cell carried in its
nucleus the genetic sequence is not just
of a single species but every naturally
occurring species of grape that the
verona boot had ever heard of and if
those people hadn't heard of a grape it
wasn't worth knowing about in addition
it carried excerpts from the genetic
sequences of thousands of different
berries fruits flowers and herbs just
those snatches of data that when invoked
by the biochemical messaging system of
the host cell produced flavor from
molecules each nucleus was an archive
faster than the great library of bars
storing codes for shaping almost every
molecule nature had ever produced that
left an impression on the human
olfactory system a given vine could not
express all these genes at once it
couldn't be a hundred species of grape
at the same time so it decided which of
these genes to express which grape to be
which flavors to borrow based on some
impossibly murky and
ambiguous data gathering and decision
making process that the rhona boot had
hand coded into its proteins no nuance
of sun soil weather wind was too subtle
for the library grape to take into
account nothing the cultivator did or
failed to do went undetected or failed
to have its consequences in the flavor
of the juice the library grape was
legendary for its skill in penetrating
the sutter fuges of wine makers who are
so arrogant as to believe they could
trick it into being the same grape two
seasons in a row
so he goes on here and he talks about
you know
different ways in which this can can go
wrong can pan out and then he talks
about fanatics like fra oral one of one
of the important characters in this
story who had made the library group his
library grape
his advocation right
so what do we have here we have a
connection to
grape growing genetics gastronomy
terroir you know all of this being
carried out within the constant all of
this being carried out by a boots all of
this
done to produce some some you know great
products
so and this kind of gives you an idea
it's not just people sitting there doing
you know high-level mathematics on
chalkboards and you know thinking about
philosophy there's all these other
aspects of the
life and world involved
i do want to mention something about uh
some of the orders that are that are
involved in this
um
[Music]
so
we'll run through this very quickly
and then perhaps we'll hit later on on
some of the key themes involved right so
the
halicarnians are connected to saint
holocarn or any of the other orders that
claim descent from this split between
the semantic and syntactic faculties
they're often seen as the opponents of
the prokians
the parokians are connected to saint
proc or any of the other orders that
claim dissent from the syntactic
faculties the prokians are in a certain
respect nominalists in the sense that we
would use the term and the holocarnians
are in a certain respect platonists in
in a way that you know they they believe
in
some
special better
world that looks a lot like plato's
world of the forms which we'll talk
about in in a bit um and then you know
there's there's other groups as well the
fanians split off from the prokians they
collaborate with the holocardians in
advance advancing genetic sequencing
technology
they get disbanded
and a lot of them join the
eta right um
who are the ito the eats are yet another
group that aren't really in order as
such and by the way their their name
actually comes from information
technology and then there's a whole
bunch of possible a's
the eda are a artisanal cast that are
tolerated in the
contents built around the great clocks
the eta
maintain all the subsystems that that
employ what they call syntactic devices
their their task is to operate and
maintain these while being separated
from the avut and we're going to see the
ita being brought together with the
avoot as the story goes on
um
adhari and the edharian order is founded
um by saint eddhar they focus on theorex
and metathericks and uh are are on the
halacarnian side this is where um
part of the story actually takes place
in the beginning
and that's you know where um erasmus is
being brought up
um two other really important orders
that we can talk about the ringing veil
right the ringing veil are people who
focus
on vail lore which is physical combat
techniques and the development of
strategy mind they also have a really
interesting
discussion that doesn't get quite
followed out in thinking about
emergencies
times and places where a radical
important decision has to be made
and where one has to act
then there's the lorites the warheads
are a particularly interesting order
founded by saint laura um
the basis of their their order is st
laura's proposition which states all
possible ideas have already been found
there is nothing new to discover
what do the laurites do they are
perpetually
you know in relation to the other orders
where a new idea is found saying
oh well that's not really that new of an
idea it it's already found back here
somewhere else and interestingly this
this idea uh about uh you know all
possible ideas have already been found
was itself um let me see if i can find
this this reference
um
this this idea itself is the last real
new idea you could call it a
meta idea right here we go so there's a
discussion that takes place really early
on
every idea the human mind could come up
with had already been come up with by
that time it's a very influential idea
wait a minute wasn't saint laurent
laura's idea a new idea according to
orthodox paleolithes it was the last
idea and he's well okay what have we all
been doing here for the 2100 years since
the last idea has come up with it
yeah to be blunt about it not everybody
agrees with this proposition everybody
loves to hate the lorites some call her
a warmed over mr gog and worse but
lorites are good to have around why
whenever anyone comes up with an idea
that they think is new the lorites
converge on it like jackals and try to
prove it's actually 5 000 years old or
something more often than not they're
right
isn't that isn't that great now there
are a few other movers and shakers that
we should talk about
one is the lineage so the lineage is
pre-mathic
etheric tradition
that was looking for a deeper
understanding of what's called the
highly and theoretical world
or
it's got an origin earlier than cartos
and her discipline
and they are you know
sort of like behind the scenes operating
for
millennia and they play an important
role
in in the plot that is going to develop
so that is probably enough at this point
in time about the world building the
last thing that we have to say is that
all of this takes place at a time
of
shake-up of of emergence to use the you
know the
veil uh uh
consents ideas
in which the secular
and the
uh consent of world are going to come
together in interesting unusual ways to
face a common enemy
but that's probably enough
about that i will just say this
i've only scratched the surface on the
incredibly complex world that is
depicted and described
within this massive volume so you know i
invite you to read it yourself and learn
more about that
i've found that reading reviews of
literature can be quite helpful both if
you haven't read the book already
and if you've already read the book and
i'm talking about good reviews and i
don't mean good in the sense of glowing
or
positive reviews the sort of silliness
that you see on the backs of
covers like you know for example in time
whatever happened to the great novel of
ideas that has morphed into science
fiction and stevenson as its foremost
practitioner you know those sort of
butt-kissing blurbs we could call them
right
that's not particularly helpful
unless it happens to be absolutely true
um but you know given that everybody
everybody's book has wonderful things
like that on it they're probably not
right especially if we include terms
like foremost or best or you know
relative terms
instead i want to see reviews that have
some meat that have some teeth that
challenge us that have something that
they put on the table and so that can be
helpful in you know before you read the
book getting some sense of is this going
to be a good book or a bad book should i
read it should i avoid it
what am i putting myself in for but i
think it's also very helpful once you've
actually read a book to read somebody
else's reviews and be like oh yeah that
person they add something to my look at
it maybe i was too hasty in judging this
over here
but it's also nice to get some
corroboration right from another person
that you're not your responses aren't
completely uh excendri
eccentric you know or extrinsic or um
off-base right that there's other people
are bothered by some of these aspects or
enjoyed aspects as well so
i've assembled a number
of i think quite good reviews in that
sense i disagree with quite a few of
them on some things but i think that
they can be quite helpful to go through
you might as we're reading these respond
to them uh in you know the comments or
in the chat or stuff like that or just
take some notes and see what you think
so here's the first one a very short one
by andrew mckee in the telegraph
i think this novel is wonderful so i
don't want to put you off but let's be
clear there is plenty to put you off
there is a strong case for thinking this
book utterly tiresome please don't
you'll miss quite a lot if you do
that is what belongs on the back cover
of this book that would be the best
blurb i could think of because it's it's
very honest and it's kind of paradoxical
right this is a tiresome book there are
things that are tiresome about it we're
going to get into some of that in just a
bit
and yet
if you can persevere and plow through
and get acclimated to
the narrative world that were
we're working within you're actually
going to
like it quite a bit so i mean we can say
this i think about other people's
fantasy or sci-fi or horror pick
whatever else kinds of worlds as well
let's talk about the next one now the
next one is a glowing kiss buddy you
know i'm so clever kind of thing by
andrew leonard at salon
anathem pulls off what most writers
would never dare attempt to just
simultaneously a page turner and a
philosophical argument an adventure
novel and an extended existential
meditation a physics lesson sermon and
ripping good yarn
anathem also resonates with social
observations rooted in our time right
now on earth the names have changed but
the geometry remains the same
if you are already a fan of stevenson
you will not be disappointed you will be
utterly engrossed
if you like a little dash of philosophy
in your science fiction you will be
delighted if you wrote a dissertation on
german idealism you will think you've
died and gone to heaven can i hear an
amen
if you don't like philosophy hate math
and desire more character development
than kant and your fiction best to stay
away
now this is some glib [ __ ] isn't it
um and you know there's there's some
bits of truth to it um
it is not a page turner until you get at
least halfway through it right and then
it really does pick up that way
is the whole thing a philosophical
argument or an extended existential
meditation
nah not really there's lots of
philosophy in it
i wouldn't say the whole thing is a
philosophical argument and that shows
that this reviewer doesn't either
doesn't know what he's talking about or
was just playing fast and loose with
words to seem like he's he's cleverer
than he is
um i do think that you know if you like
stevenson already you'll probably like
this one kind of the way it works with
most authors um if you like a little
dash of philosophy in your science
fiction you will be delighted sure that
that's quite true
if you wrote a dissertation on german
idealism you'll think you have died and
gone to heaven that is complete utter
pandering nonsense right um
first off there's not a lot of german
idealism connected with this more you
know there's platonism there's you know
uh
quantum mechanics things there's things
on on philosophy of language so bringing
in the thing about kant and german
idealism is just pure pure pandering for
people who might have encountered that
in the you know
online sphere with references to it or
in intro to philosophy classes
in a way the more philosophy that you
know that that stevenson is working with
and referencing
in a way the less satisfying the book
actually turns out to be
let's look at the next one now this is
uh
this is a much more pejorative one
oh anathem will certainly be admired for
its intelligence ambition control and
ingenuity but loved
enjoyed
the made-up language is rebarbative the
plot moves with elephantine slowness
much is confusing the process of
decipherment actually drives the book as
the characters and reader try to figure
things out in big capitals every so
often we just stop for a long info dump
or debate about cosmology philosophy
semantics or similar glitzy arcana for
the most part stevenson's prose lacks
any particular grace or beauty at least
to my ear and while he can be mildly
satirical at times these precious
moments are few on the other hand the
descriptions of buildings machines
events seem to go on for millennia sex
is referred to but never actually seen
alas there's worse this is michael
dierda in the washington post
i'd say he's off base i mean i mean do
we do we need a lot of sex in stories
there's enough stories out there with
tons of it in there that you know that
actually get complained about too much
sex in this one so that's kind of a
weird one to uh be concerned with um
you know a lot of this is is pretty
subjective stuff but
we'll say this
loved or enjoyed
well a lot of people do love and enjoy
this book that's why it got recommended
to me
and that's why i ultimately did this i
don't love it and i did enjoy parts of
it um but i recognize that
there's many other people out there with
takes and many people really did love
this book and and still do
the made-up language
uh yeah that's that's a big issue with
the book um i think a lot of us find it
off-putting in in different ways um the
plot moves with elephantine slowness uh
that's a little bit of
exaggeration but it is it is pretty slow
moving in the first part much is
confusing but then you know he admits
that well much has to be confusing
because this is a
book that has the plot of characters and
readers trying to figure things out so
it is confusing but it's not confusing
just to be confusing or because
stevenson couldn't handle
um the plot that he's developing it's
confusing because the characters are
confused about what's going on so that's
kind of a good point actually
here's another thing this is by charles
sol and tor
and this this also has to do with
the language stuff
it all feels just familiar enough that
we're never completely lost but it also
feels very other very different very
fresh
that alone is an incredible feat of
writerly engineering it's hard enough to
come up with one cool name for something
much less 100 or so each feeling
appropriate and right but then the
really truly awesome thing
stevenson pulls yet another card out of
his deck and reveals that arb
feels similar to earth because it almost
is earth it's a parallel dimension where
the language evolves slightly
differently but that doesn't mean our
earth isn't part of the story two we
discover this when a minor character in
the story is revealed to have been an
alien interloper all along an alien from
our world earth called la terre in the
book because the alien also happens to
be french
our own history on our own world exists
within the world of anthem you and i are
part of the story it's just mostly left
off stage so a spoiler there right uh i
i said that there would be spoilers in
this this uh uh discussion um
so you know i mean this this is a decent
explanation of why the names all have to
be this weird you know
sons so and
just almost like one letter off
when it comes to to things right and
you know
this provides a justification it doesn't
eliminate the annoyingness
of the the language that eventually you
just have to get past i think
here's another one longer uh passage
uh from christopher brooke mirror in the
guardian
i think there's some really interesting
insights here
the obvious early point of reference
is merv and peak's gorman gas novels
as stevenson immerses the reader in a
world of ritual and order the reasons
for which are not entirely understood by
their adherents these are people who
think as a vocation deconstructing the
reasoning behind every statement yet
even in such a culture ritual can take
hold and impose and order whole
centuries after the reasons for it have
been forgotten
arbs is a civilization several thousand
years more mature than our own i say
mature rather than advanced as there's a
deep sense of technological ages largely
forgotten
buried under cataclysm however
the beating heart of this novel is
philosophy if i may borrow an analogy
from professor stephen law at times
anathem is not so much a workout in the
philosophy gym as philosophy extreme
sports the history of the avut is
punctuated by the breakthrough ideas of
sounds all of them replicating concepts
familiar to us here on earth through
plato euclid leibniz newton and so on
edmond husserl's copper ashtray becomes
adamant's bowl occam's razor becomes
saunt garden steel yard this is more
than mere facsimile the most powerful
and controversial idea among the avvoot
concerns the highly enthuric world and
the question of whether the same ideas
will occur independently to thinkers on
different planets because there are
certain transcendental truths prime
numbers the value of pi the laws of
geometry that exist on some higher plane
so a lot a lot of things going on there
right
i think he's right
that we can see a parallel here
between
what is going on in the maths and the
contents
essentially the the world of the or the
inner world of the uh boots right
we can see something
like that
uh in the gorman gas novels i also think
that i mean we might think
of other um
series you know gene wolf's um
you know
works come to mind here he does similar
things with
language and
you know it's a dying earth way in the
the future
um books of the new sun right same thing
with ritual that's not understood why do
we do things this way ah who knows you
know we just keep doing it like this um
i would say that you know speaking of
dying earth jack vance and also tanneth
lee's stuff
certainly seem to
cover the similar ground as well
although you know they're not really
centered around
entire uh
not even classes but like lineages of
people who are working on these sorts of
things so that's you know that that's
quite interesting
um i like this point about arabs being a
civilization more mature but not you
know not necessarily more advanced than
our own that is a really great um
idea
is anathem uh
not a workout in the philosophy gym but
more philosophy extreme sports i would
say both of those don't really
work because i mean extreme sports
you got to do lots and lots of training
for it
i guess you know insofar as like when we
watch extreme sports and we see displays
of virtuosity it could be like that
because that we're not getting an awful
lot of
real you know
um
deployment of those things i mean i'd
say that you know um
a couple platonic dialogues probably
have more
interesting and deep running philosophy
than the entirety of of this this work
but
pick the right dialogues right obviously
not the ion or you know things like that
and you know he does lift stuff
basically out of um the philosophy of
our world
and put it into the mouths of his
characters and the minds of the
characters
but there is a real problem being raised
here in terms of the highly etheric
world so i think that you know brookmyre
really did zero in on things here
um dave itzkoff in the new york times
brings up plato's republic and he says
that
is in book 10
socrates delineates three categories of
art one which uses another which makes
the third which imitates them
the last of these three socrates holds
in the lowest regard because it's a copy
of the copy of the truth an inferior who
marries an inferior and has inferior
offspring my reluctant conclusion
is that anathem spends so much time
engaged in copying
in conjuring up alternative formulations
of our real world science and religion
that it forgets to come up with much
that is new or true
too much of the book is dominated by
lengthy dialectical debates whose
conclusions are hardly earth-shattering
what's worse the book's fixation on
dialogue leads erasmus and stevenson to
simply tell us what is happening or has
happened in pivotal scenes instead of
allowing us to see the events for
ourselves through descriptive action and
when erasmus and his confederates at
last make their way onto that alien ship
you may wonder what all this has to do
with the larger theme stevenson spends
the first 300 pages of his 900 page
novel laying out i think this is an
unfair review
i think that uh it's it's partly right i
think that there's there's a
it's a dangerous strategy to just engage
in copying what we've got here over into
a
world here
and
you
know to find out that that
they're copying something from plato or
hysterol or
akamer
pick whoever else you like
if you've if if you're getting
introduced to these ideas for the first
time or you're kind of at an
intermediate level it's really fun to
recognize that and to play around with
it i would say somebody who did way
better job at that is philip k dick in
his novels where people are talking
about you know particular ideas and then
really exploring them
i don't know that that happens that much
in some of what's going on in here
so i think that's right about it but
the book's fixation on dialogue leads
erasmus to simply tell us what's
happening i think that the descriptions
are perfectly good
it doesn't all have to be you know third
person narration or something i i
thought i i was able to get into the
story
myself and i think that it's cough just
kind of
he missed something when he's saying uh
when they make their way into the alien
ship you may wonder what all this has to
do with the larger themes stevenson
spends the first 300 pages well i mean
there's there's lots of connections
there so i think it's koff was probably
an inattentive reader by the time that
he got to the end which can you know is
understandable since this is such a
massive tome right
here is another interesting
one um
anathem offers readers a very steep
learning curve during the first 200
pages however once erasmus world is
established it's easy to enjoy this
adventurous funny and intelligent
science fiction novel yes those first
200 pages could be difficult but
remember soon you'll be reading about
mathematicians and philosophers
defending their planet against alien
invaders it's also worth taking the time
to do your homework on the history of
philosophy and quantum mechanics both of
these subjects will be discussed in
detail though stevenson's taken the
liberty of changing most of the words
consequently there's a need for several
lectures over the course of the novel
and stephenson has devised
several means by which the about can
meet discuss and debate these ideas so
as not to become repetitive my favorite
might be called the messel in which
several senior reboot dine and discuss
ideas one more junior votes serve them
the junior vote can express their
boredom with the dinner by leaving the
room at which point we're treated to
someone gossipy academic discussion in
the servitors area about the dinners
discussion at other times stevenson's
characters simply walk along while
engaged in conversations that recall
socratic questioning add to this
stevenson's tendency to engage in
lengthy digressions and we have a novel
that's perfectly suited for stevenson's
fans
however anathem might not be the best
novel for newcomers it's certainly not
for stevenson skeptics it took me
several tries to get past arb's jargon
and engage with erasmus story having
said that once i did get into the story
i did not resent the effort i was hooked
and quite sad to see the story end
anathem is notable for many reasons
particularly the detailed rules and the
history of the mathic world but perhaps
the best thing about the book is that
readers who finish it will find
themselves wanting to start over that
was ryan scar doll in fantasy literature
so that's an interesting point i would
be genuinely
uh intrigued to find out how many
readers did in fact
want to start over i did not myself have
that
particular take it was more like
now i'm finally at the end i think i i
wish there was more of the story i will
say that i agree with him there
but it didn't make me say wow i got to
get back into this a second time i i may
reread this in the future i don't know
but um maybe there are some people who
are like man i gotta go back to the
beginning now and reread this a second
time which you know would make sense for
stevenson fans i really like this this
discussion here
about um
[Music]
how it is that stevenson
managed in a literary way to bring in
these
expository discussions and you know he's
not the only author to do this this is
something that goes you know way back
into speculative fiction literature
lovecraft did this you know you find uh
exposition like this in dracula and
braum stoker we can think of all sorts
of people who who do this i mean it's
interesting stanislaw lem
does this himself and also criticizes
other people for introducing
ideas that don't really work that are
just made up stuff ava and voigt you
know is is somebody who both lem and uh
damien knight went after on that account
stevenson is is referring to things
that have you know a real
basis in the history of philosophy or in
quantum mechanics or in the you know
conceptions about consciousness that are
that are going on today
um
and i i think he actually does a pretty
good job in introducing these things
somebody else who also does similar
things in his works umberto echo you
know if you've actually read umberto
echo's
texts not his novels but his texts like
on philosophy of language or semiotics
you'll find him basically
having the characters
give lectures that are coming out of the
echoes books
that doesn't make it bad it's a question
of how it's done
there is a very steep learning curve as
uh scardal points out in the first 200
pages
but you know there once you break um
it does become a good story
finally joe walton and tor who's written
several different things about anathem
i started thinking about why stevenson
had chosen to set the story in a
different world rather than set it 4 000
years or so in our own future
there's a good plot reason of course
which is having people from our world
show up later one of the big reveals
right
but he could just as well have said it 4
000 years in the future and had aliens
rather than people from our world and
other cosmoses
since the first time i read antithem
i've been assured by people i trust who
know about science that essentially the
many world's alternative physics stuff
is all wrong while the french is cute in
that it could have been aliens and been
fine the bit i like least about
anathem is the bid in space the
probabilistic millennium ex makina stuff
so he could have lost that not annoyed
marissa and other physics people and
kept everything i adore about the book
i actually disagree um
i think
you know i would say the you know
is the physics stuff all wrong no it's
it's pretty much impossible for it to be
all wrong
and i think there's a lot of things that
are still being hashed out i'm not
necessarily endorsing uh the the physics
and the speculations about consciousness
in the book myself but i'm more willing
to go along with them
i don't know about this i think there's
something to be gained contra joe walton
by having uh
earth come into it it's almost a it
reminds me of borehase and the way that
he writes stuff with his kinds of
reveals
in which we find out that oh no no we've
been in the story all along so
a lot of great stuff in these reviews i
would say i know i've taken a lot of
time talking about this but you know it
hits a lot of the important plot points
and i think this is well worth
discussing
in the interest of time because i don't
want this to get overly long and also
because of the way this novel is
structured i'm not going to do what i've
done in many other
of these these talks which is to focus
in on individual philosophical themes
and exploit and explore them in great
detail
and then leave the others out of course
because we can only cover so many
instead i'm going to shift our focus
to the
plot of the novel
which as it unfolds brings some of these
themes in
very explicitly and also gives us a
really interesting
twist to think about
so
we've got you know erasmus and who's you
know coming of age in
his consent and um you know connected
with this fra orlo who's going to get
kicked out very soon anathem is going to
be pronounced against him and he's going
to be sent away um erasmus himself also
gets in trouble and winds up having to
you know engage with this punishment
called the book right
we're going to we're gonna put that
aside for the moment and think about the
bigger picture which is that things are
changing there's something happening in
the sky
that erasmus and orlo and others are
very interested in
as it's to turn out this is not a
military thing it's not a satellite
it is an alien spaceship
and
this is being kept under wraps
why well because
nobody's quite sure exactly what to do
about it and there's there's some
high-level coordination that is going to
be taking place between the secular
world
specifically their military and decision
makers
and the
uh avutz the
the people who really know science and
work on it and they're going to become
connected and there's actually going to
be this this great sending forth from
the
maths and contents of of the
people who might be able to work on it
and erasmus is one of those who is sent
out along with as he finds on the way
this guy fra jad who is a thousander
he's he's in that special part uh you
know that special math that is almost
you know disconnected from the outside
world openly opens its doors once every
thousand
years and there's lots of you know great
adventure story happening on the way and
revelations and wondering about what's
going on and i'm gonna sort of fast
forward us
to
where the the aliens are actually
being encountered
and where they realize something really
key
the matter that the aliens
are made of
is not the same thing as the matter from
the cosmos i almost said our cosmos but
our cosmos is one of the aliens right uh
la terre is earth in this story so arb
the matter that people are composed of
is slightly different than those of
later or the other three
worlds as it turns out that all these
people come from and this has some
significant effects
you can eat the food of a different
cosmos
but you can't digest it you can't derive
any nourishment from it you can breathe
the air
but it's going to mess you up and it
takes a long period of acclimation to be
able to
use the oxygen
that is in somebody else's cosmoses
air
and
it gets even trippier we find out that
part of the backstory of what has been
going on and we find this out from a guy
whose name is jules vernon but he's not
the julesburn right
we find out that there is a
plurality of worlds indeed which gets
gets brought up at this um
assembly right
and um it's it's being dismissed by frau
lordiger who is a
member of the these you know prokian the
rhetoricians right
and um
here we go plurality of word worlds he
says sounds impressive i haven't the
faintest idea of what it means to some
here the mere fact of the geometers
that's the name for the aliens existence
proves that there is at least one other
world and at one level it's quite
trivial but since it appears i'm the
token procreation at this messel i shall
play my role and say this we have
nothing in common with these geometers
no shared experiences no common culture
until that changes we can't communicate
with them why not because language is
nothing more than a stream of symbols
that are perfectly meaningless until we
associate them in our minds with meaning
a process of acculturation until we
share experiences with the geometers and
thereby begin to develop a shared
culture in effect to merge our culture
with theirs we cannot communicate with
them and their efforts to communicate
with us will continue to be just as
incomprehensible as the gestures they've
made so far for example throwing the
warden of heaven out the airlock
dropping a fresh murder victim into a
cult site and rotting a volcano now this
is a very interesting point
and lodiger would be correct if it
wasn't for the fact
that
something else is is going on and this
is a good place to bring in
one of these key ideas
this is of the hilayanthyric world which
the prokians
totally reject and the
fanians thought that belief in was
actually a kind of religion and what is
this hylactheric world
it is the platonic world of the forms
understood not just say through plato
but the way that neoplatonus would
understand it
the name used by adherence of protism to
denote the higher plane of existence
populated by perfect geometric forms is
coming from the glossary
theorems and other pure ideas knowns
named after hylia one of the two
daughters of canos right
and so there's a simple way of
understanding this and a complex way of
understanding this and we can say
similar things with with you know
platonism whether it's the platonism of
plato's dialogues or the
fuller conceptions of platonism
developed in middle and later platonism
you know neoplatonism or those developed
by bringing it into a religious
perspective in our own times so we have
simple
and complex protism simple protism says
that there's two
cosmic two cosmoses right
and one is more purely
highly in
than the other
so you've got the highland theoretic
world the world of the forms and then
you have the arborin causal domain the
world that we see right plato talked
about this as the
visible and the invisible the
the tangible material the
noetic the intelligible world that we
could grasp and the information leads
from and causality from one cosmos to
another and it is unidirectional right
and so you know this is typical
platonism as we've encountered it in the
past right then we have something a
little bit trickier and this is where it
gets very very interesting complex
protism developed by sir uthantin and
her fid fra erasmus the namesake the guy
that that erasmus is named after in this
involves multiple cosmoses
that are arranged in an order
from the more purely highland to the
less purely highland and the hilaine
flow
exists between these cosmo these
cosmoses
and so um
in this way
the cosmoses actually
do share something in common
it isn't the case that the people from
the other cosmos
would have nothing in common with us
nothing no connection with us
they are interpreting the highland
etheric world in a different way
they are living things out in a
different manner but there are going to
be similarities and interestingly the
cosmoses
can
lead from one to the other can call
from one to the other and so we find out
that uh lodiger's worries about this you
know multi-world hypothesis
aren't real worries after all
and in this this
gathering they set up a faraday
cage right and and here's where we start
to to uh realize some stuff so this is
where one of the big plot twists happens
right he says um in my world said
javaren we call it a faraday cage right
in our world earth
he stood up and shrugged his bolt over
his head then tossed it to the floor
um i could you know look on the face of
a living alien judging from the back of
his head and torso i judged he was the
same race as the dead woman who'd come
down with the probe as we're going to
find out that's actually his wife right
beneath a sort of undershirt a small
device was attached to his skin with
tape he throws it on there i am jules
verne durand of la terre the world you
know as antarct oregon is from the world
of hornwood which you have designated
panjay you'd best get them inside the
faraday cage and they they do that and
then he starts unveiling the story
you know
we've been traveling through the cosmos
and there has been a sequence
of
four different
cosmoses connected together they're all
on this massive colony ship which has
changed purpose and
you could say governance several times
and there's actually a division between
the four different human races on this
colony ship all of whom have different
uh you could say material none of whom
are complete are completely compatible
with each other's uh cosmos their air
their food their water all those sorts
of things and they they move first one
goes to another planet and then uses the
resources takes on some of the people
then they move to another cosmos another
earth
another orth another arb right
and with each one there's a different
set of mindsets and capacities as taken
on then they run into arb and arb is in
a certain way
a more ideal
dimension a more ideal planet and
they're the ones who are actually able
to put up real resistance and force a
new
we could call it new manner of
association a new
uh diplomacy a new
working out and sharing of information
and that is what happens
in the very end of this story there's
lots of other things that are happening
along the way like an assault on the
alien spaceship and traveling you know
to to the the the arctic realm and fall
you know fighting people and all sorts
of other really great stuff but that is
the basic plot point and what we could
call this
is you could say in some respects a
triumph
of an attenuated sort of platonism
over
nominalism there's more as well it's
also connected with the conception of
human consciousness that human
consciousness itself would be operating
within
many possible ways of grasping the
cosmos which can also be separate
cosmoses and that through you know study
application intuition all these things
that are available to us as human beings
that can be refined
maybe we can even manipulate which
cosmos is
the real in a you know
scare quote sense cosmos that we're in
so we have platonism and nominalism we
have other uh cosmoses and what it would
be like to be an alien being who's not
completely alien
alternate timelines alternate histories
alternate modes of social development
and all sorts of very interesting
speculations on consciousness coming
together in this novel of which i've
basically
just scratched the surface but this
should be hopefully enough to
get you into it
you